bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission où on va vous expliquer comment
dépenser des milliards pour rien
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ces
caches une émission consacrée cette
semaine au plan de relance chine etats
unis union européenne les pays n'ont pas
lésiné sur les milliards pour tenter de
remettre à flot des économies malmenées
par la pandémie de kobe de 19 on va
regarder en détail ses plans de relance
quelle stratégie pour quel pays qui s'en
sort le mieux fait pour en parler
évidemment olivier delamarche bonjour
olivier bonjour au score et à vos côtés
véronique riches florès économiste et
président de riches florès reasearch
bonjour mélangées aux graisses bienvenus
allez on va commencer par un tour
d'horizon des plans de relance qui nous
intéresse union européenne chine etats
unis tous les détails avec le tiroir
cash d'antoine face à
[Musique]
la relance c'est avant tout une affaire
de plans enfin parlons plutôt de
recettes avec toujours le même
ingrédient des gros sous des milliards
et encore des milliards il s'agit pour
les différents pays de faire en sorte
que leur économie tourne de nouveau à
plein régime que la croissance revienne
et avec elle les investissements bref
que la machine abîmées par le cos vide
redémarre en europe une partie des plans
de relance des pays est financé par next
generation ue le plan de relance
européen et ses 750 milliards d'euros
mais chaque pays a son propre plan de
relance et s'ils n'ont pas les mêmes
sommes il cherche avant tout même s'il y
a quelques spécificités as accès sur la
transition écologique la modernisation
industrielle où les technologies
d'avenir aux usa joe biden et ses 1900
milliards elle lui en premier lieu
cherché à stimuler la consommation en
donnant directement de l'argent aux
ménages les plus en difficulté via des
chèques qui sont arrivés dans leur boîte
aux lettres il a ensuite dégainer encore
plus pour les infrastructures avec une
relance financés finalement à hauteur de
4000 milliards de dollars en chine le
pouvoir mise lui au contraire plutôt sur
la production que la consommation et sur
des plans de relance locaux en envoyant
aux gouvernements des différentes
régions du pays des fonds pour mieux
s'adapter aux particularités des
différents territoires normal le pays
est bien plus grand mais la chine
profite également des plans de relance
des autres pays alors compensé avants
locaux vides qu'elles se détacher peu à
peu de son statut d' usine du monde il y
à ce qu'on pourrait appeler un pas en
arrière des entreprises américaines et
européennes boosté par les plans de
relance se retrouve à acheter du made in
china permettant ainsi à la chine de
faire tourner ses usines à nouveau à
plein régime et capter ainsi des fonds
dédiés à la relance des autres reste à
savoir parmi toutes ces stratégies
quelle sera celle qui s'avérera la plus
payante pour réellement relancer
l'économie effacer les affres du coc
vide et on vient de le voir les sommes
allouées sont faramineuses 750 milliards
d'euros pour l'union européenne c'est
cinq fois plus pour les états unis la
chine elle est autour de 480 milliards
d'euros des montants sans précédent
olivier à ces sommes sont elles
justifiées et puis d'abord est ce que
ces plans de relance était nécessaire
alors si vous voulez moi les plans de
relance ccht de la croissance avec de la
bête c'est quelque chose qui alors
ponctuellement vous donne une illusion
de croissance mais malheureusement ça on
sait ce que ça ce que ça vaut c'est à
dire que vous avez des d une croissance
qui est une croissance
structurelle si vous voulez qui est une
croissance potentielle des pays qui
aujourd'hui est très faible pourquoi
très faible pour des raisons qui sont à
la fois démographique qui sont de le
progrès technique etc et est donc ce
problème là n'est absolument pas réglé
parce que vous fait imprimer quelques
milliards par la banque centrale et
voulait distribuer alors vous pouvez les
distribuer autant que vous voulez
simplement en en fabriquant et en en
distribuant comme le fait monsieur by
donne un vous aurez de l'inflation
forcément puisque on vous donne de
l'argent que vous dépensez directement
et donc que l'inflation récupérera ce
que vous avez ce que vous avez mis
sachant qu'en plus
aujourd'hui les américains utilisent ce
chèque en grande partie pour aller
ouvrir des comptes chez robin hood et
est allé spéculer sur le bitcoin donc si
vous voulez on est quand même dans un
toujours dans une histoire qui qui est
on marche on continue de marcher sur la
tête sur les sur les différents plans de
relance après vous avez le plan de
relance européen on va en parler je
pense aux qui est une aberration
puisque
non à peine démarrait donc treize mois
après son son son acceptation à peine
démarré
en fait pour la france on paye plus
cause parce qu'on reçoive on ne voit pas
bien l'intérêt qu'il pouvait s'en passer
l'on pouvait s'en passer oui il fa c'est
à dire qu' on aurait pu s'en passer si
on n'avait pas une bande d'incompétents
notoires depuis trente ans on aurait pu
s'en passer parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
pas il n'y a pas que le coc vide on est
dans cette situation en fait depuis
longtemps on est dans cette situation
depuis 2008 qui je vous rappel n'a
jamais été réglé on a mis la poussière
sous le tapis et là on s'étonne qu'elle
ressorte à l'occasion de cet événement
du coc vide mais le coc vide est un
accélérateur le coc vide est un
amplificateur
mais le co vide n'est pas la raison de
ce qui se passe actuellement dans les
économies et dans toutes les économies
que ce soit l'économie américaine que ce
soit l'économie que les économies
européennes le mal est beaucoup plus
profond que ça il a commencé bien avant
ça et là aujourd'hui on fait mine de le
redécouvrir mais c'est quelque chose qui
est là depuis le tant est qu'ils ne se
réglera pas simplement parce que les
banques centrales vont acheter des
obligations sur le marché ça
comment peut-on penser que le
quantitative easing est la réponse à
tous nos maux véronique riches florès
résume olivier mais pour vous les plans
de relance cht de la croissance avec de
la dette vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse n'a été pareil même question est
ce qu'on aurait pu faire sans alors la
réponse oui je suis d'accord de toute
façon sur la définition un plan de
relance où aller l'état va s'endetter
pour investir dans l'économie et seuil
est de restaurer des ressources de
croissance future
est ce qu'on aurait pu s'en passer
olivier l'a dit c'est pas un si pâle
copie c'est c'est les 20 années qui ont
précédé dont l'épisode de la crise de
2008 et qu'est ce qu'on a fait au
lendemain de la crise de 2008 on a
finalement mis les banques centrales
aux manettes de nos économies et on les
a laissés gérer l'ensemble des retombées
de la cré et ça ça a conduit
effectivement à quoi injecté beaucoup de
liquidités dans l'économie à faire que
les marchés financiers se sont porté
beaucoup mieux que l'économie réelle ce
qui a eu pour effet ce qu'on appelle un
effet d'éviction c'est à dire ça à
chasser l'investissement dans l'économie
au profit de l'investissement financier
donc si vous regardez les choses comme
cela plus l'impact la crise de coheed
qui est venue exacerber les ai faits
antérieurs déjà très néfaste ma réponse
est oui nous avions absolument besoin de
plans de relance pour un pour venir
accompagnés ou se substituer à ces
politiques monétaires on en est loin
pour l'instant voilà on a les deux qui
marche de concert donc
c'est pas satisfaisante et
réorienter l'investissement
là où il est nécessaire c'est à dire
dans l'économie réelle pour contrer les
effets du vieillissement contre et
l'hyper dépendance notamment européennes
mais pas que à l'égard des produits
chinois ou de la production chinoise et
éviter des ruptures les pénuries ou tout
simplement la dépendance économique
elles manquent de souveraineté une fille
née et
et y
préparer la transition environnementale
qui requiert beaucoup d'investissements
qui crée beaucoup d'incertitudes sur les
perspectives économiques la
réglementation à venir et donc qui
paralyse l'initiative privée c'est en
cela qu'on pouvait défendre des plans de
relance ou des initiatives structurelle
du public alors investi les plans de
relance du public c'est quoi c'est pas
l'investissement financé advitam eternam
par le secteur public c'est d'abord la
définition d'une stratégie structurelles
où on veut aller ce qu'on veut faire
c'est quoi les l'europe de l'énergie de
demain où l'europe de des villes de
demain
investir pour lancer la machine
en espérant un relais du secteur privé
est ce qu'on a ces composants plat vous
l'avez compris on en est très loin d'où
effectivement le grand scepticisme
aujourd'hui par rapport à ces
initiatives qui ressemble dans beaucoup
de cas c'est particulièrement flagrant
dans le cas américain avec l'envoi de
ces chèques qui n'a aucun effet
structurel absolument pas il s'agissait
juste de remettre le consommateur devant
son porte monnaie ou
éventuellement faire spéculer un petit
peu donc on est complètement à côté de
la plaque l'autre plan structurel des
démocrates étaient beaucoup plus plus
intéressant mais lui il est bloqué
justement vous parlez aussi donc des
banques centrales est ce que ces plans
de relance sont compatibles avec les
politiques monétaires actuelles bah
c'est une des grandes questions est
fondamentalement je crois que c'est la
limite également de ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui c'est précisément ce qu'on
observe très nettement c'est que toutes
les annonces de relance dont certaines
étaient je leur dis plutôt justifiée à
mon sens est bien ont servi deux raisons
supplémentaires ou d'arguments
supplémentaires pour faire monter les
bourses pourquoi parce que notamment ont
continué des politiques de quantitative
easing c'est à dire d'injections
massives de liquidités et là on voit
bien il ya erreur de casting et qui a
fait un gros souci parce
qu'effectivement on risque tout
simplement d'avoir de tels effets
d'éviction qui restera plus grand chose
pour l'économie réelle
oui alors deux choses moi je préciserai
parce que c'est vrai qu'on entend
souvent
que l'état
va mettre de l'argent sur la table
laitages rappel qui sait c'est nous
c'est pas un monsieur avec un gros
chéquier un gros con tre manque c'est
nous donc quand l'état s'endette
c'est nous qu'on en est comme si on vous
obliger à aller à la banque prendre un
emprunt c'est ça que ça veut dire l'état
c'est pas ce pas quelque chose de c'est
pas un
un chinois avec avec beaucoup d'argent
qui ferait des chèques pour nous donc
c'est nous
évidemment c'est à dire que cela se
répercutera d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est à dire soit par l'impôt qui
augmentera et et donc quand on vous
donne de l'argent on vous le donne pas
on vous oblige à l'emprunter c'est un
peu différent donc faudrait bien se
mettre ça dans la tête la deuxième chose
c'est c'est alors je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec le fait qu' on aurait pu
faire un plan de relance avec cette fois
ci en effet quelque chose qui arrive
dans l'économie réelle parce que pour
l'instant on n'en a pas vu arriver
beaucoup dans l'économie réelle et le
quantitative easing on sait très bien
que ça n'arrive pas dans l'économie
réelle donc là ça aurait pu être
intéressant la seule chose c'est que
pour ça il faut avoir une vision est pas
une vision à six mois pas une vision à
cinq ans même mais une vraie vision
c'est à dire je vous rappelle le dernier
qui a eu une vision c'est c'est le
général de gaulle et pompidou derrière
quand il sait il a il a misé sur le
nucléaire là aujourd'hui on voit bien
que c'est suivant les lobbys suivant les
le calendrier électoral suivant les
lubies
des uns et des autres qui vous disent un
coup je veux plus de nucléaire qui ferme
une centrale et puis qui le lendemain
vous disant bajan construit rêve
volontiers 4 lisez c'est la transition
écologique et numérique c'est pas une
vision assez forte pour mais c'est quoi
la transition écologique qu'est ce que
vous mettez dedans qu'est ce que vous
mettez dedans si la transition
écologique çà çà çà çà veut dire donner
de l'argent à adé à des incapables se
suivent parce que c'est des amis et que
eux ils vont vous construire des
éoliennes qui ne servent à rien encore
une fois qu'ils sont une escroquerie
total du début jusqu'à la fin donc qui
polluent les sols qui ne sont pas qui ne
sont pas possibles à recycler face est
une c'est une vraie escroquerie et on le
fait financer si c'est ça ce qu'on veut
comme transition écologique alors oui ça
va se terminer dans le mur si on a enfin
une vision économies sur les les bonnes
les bonnes choses face ce qui va nous
permettre de nous en tirer d'avoir une
une énergie pas cher comme certains pays
comme la chine d'ailleurs qui est en
train de miser gros là dessus eh bien
peut-être qu on aura un plan de relance
intéressant mais sinon fassi ou les le
sait encore une fois de l'argent jeté
par les fenêtres oui j'ai véronique
qu'on va marquer une courte pause et on
revient dans l'instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine les
plans de relance avec l'hérault nick
riches florès économiste et président de
riches florès reasearch et olivier
delamarche alors on va reparler des
stratégies de relance des différents
pays on l'a vu dans le tiroir cash lui
cible la transition écologique et la
modernisation industrielle dans son plan
aux etats-unis on préfère stimuler la
consommation des ménages alors qu'en
chine on part plutôt sur de la relance
locale véronique riches florès y at il
une stratégie qui est meilleure qu'une
autre ou alors est-ce que tout
simplement tout simplement ce n'est pas
comparable étant donné que chaque pays a
une situation bien propre
alors j'ai envie de rebondir sur ce que
disait olivier à l'instant cirque un bon
plan de relance c'est d'abord une vision
et c'est d'abord un plan qui répondent à
une ambition de long terme pour prenez
ce café by donne son premier plan
d'ailleurs ne s'appelait pas relancer un
plan de soutien immédiat le vrai plan de
relance dans le programme des démocrates
il n'est pas pour les trois prochains
mois il est sur dix ans ça ça ressemble
un peu plus à un plan de relance il
attaque il s'attaque à la fois à des
perspectives d'offre et d'amélioration
de l'offre et aux états unis il y a de
quoi faire notamment en matière
d'infrastructures d'amélioration de la
productivité et avec un à peu près
l'équivalent un grand volant sur la
demande une amélioration du niveau des
classes moyennes de l'éducation du
logement et ses puces et qui va de pair
avec une ambition de rééquilibrage du
système fiscal bon ça ça ressemble un
plan de relance est-ce que ça a des
chances d'aboutir positivement
si si ce plan là se donne les moyens
d'entraîner encore une fois les
entreprises dans leur sillage et 7 ce
moyen là iv il est décisif il marche
avec probablement un peu plus de
réglementation ou de grandes
orientations une fois que vous avez des
grandes orientations si vous voulez le
défendre il faut un peu de
réglementation et il faut forcer le
trait sauf qu'on a des entreprises hyper
endettée et ça c'est mondiale et aux
états unis en chine
on l'a vu mais en europe également c'est
beaucoup plus difficile donc de drainer
les entreprises dans le sillage de
l'action publique premièrement et vous
avez également d'abord toutes les
incertitudes sur le vieillissement les
problématiques climatiques et sera plus
tous les débats si on rajoute en europe
le manque de vision alors là pour le
coup par exemple on le voit sur au sujet
du nucléaire et de la rapidité ou la
façon dont on traite ce sujet dans une
logique de croissance plus soutenable
donc définir un vrai plan de relance ça
n'existe pas en réalité si on peut dire
il faut qu'il soit d'ampleur enfin
l'échiné des japonais nous ont fait
combien de plan de relance depuis 15 ans
1 est donc le résultat des courses il
aurait une dette publique de 250
peut-être même plus maintenant pour cent
du pilon calcul plus on suit plus mais
ils ont toujours une économie au tapis
donc c'est parce qu'ils ont fait des
ponts sur des ponts des choses qui ne
servent à rien premier plan enfin l'un
des plans de relance après la crise de
2008 ou dans ses alentours là
de sarkozy moi je m'en suis aperçu que
j'avais une petite maison à la campagne
à l'époque et du jour au lendemain
effectivement la route droit que je
prenais en une heure et demie était
encombrée de ronds-points tous les 200
mètres à peu près donc ça c'était le
plan de relance est ce que ça a apporté
quelque chose à l'économie française
absolument rien c'est de l'argent
gaspillé purement et simplement et c'est
toujours très facile c'est pour ça que
même l'idée du quoi qu'il en coûte ce
terme là est gênant parce que il en
coûte toujours quelque chose surtout
quand de l'argent et dilapidé et qui
n'est pas il garantit pas une
amélioration du niveau de croissance
structurelle de nos économies vous
évoquez aussi le rôle du secteur privé
la relance à l'est
elle est absolument enfin le secteur
privé doit participer à la relance
écoutez il ya comment comment pour le
pousser comment apprendre c'est pas
facile c'est pas facile surtout quand un
ce secteur privé déjà surendettés et
quand il a la garantie d'avoir des
projets beaucoup plus rentable que de
prendre le risque économique parce
qu'investir dans dans l'économie
aujourd'hui c'est quand même
effectivement pas tout à fait une partie
garanti il ya pas mal de raisons de
douter et de freiner finalement ce
mouvement spontané c'est ce qui justifie
quelque part un petit peu les plans de
relance sachant que
donc comment enfin le rôle du secteur
privé il est essentiel on a tous appris
à l'école le multiplicateur keynésien
c'est quoi l'état mais un et le secteur
privé mais un plus ou un foie donc c'est
ça qu'il faut garantir si on veut le
succès d'un plan de relance sinon ça
marche parce que l'état ne pourra pas de
toute façon sur la durée se substitue au
secteur privé ça marche sera
probablement pas du point de vue et
d'efficacité mais est-ce qu'on a cette
garantie là aujourd'hui je ne pense pas
et c'est bien là qui effectivement on
peut être inquiet et que probablement
norad et on va tomber dedans sans doute
un peu haut notamment en europe mais pas
que sur les retombées de ces plans de
relance à plus long terme olivier vous
êtes d'accord notamment sur le rôle du
secteur privé a mis le rôle du secteur
privé c'est
il faut le il faut pas lui il faut pas
l'embêter le secteur privé il faut pas
lui donner des sous c'est parce que
demande un chef d'entreprise chefs
d'entreprise ils demandent surtout qu'on
lui foute la paix qu'on le laisse
travailler or c'est parce qu'on fait en
france et donc
moi je suis chef d'entreprise je je je
le sais si vous voulez c'est au jeu
demande jamais personne ne demande
jamais dead ceux qui demandent des aides
et qui ne compte que sur les aides pour
vivre c'est pas des chefs d'entreprise
ce et c'est des gens qui vivent de
subventions et il ferait mieux de fermer
leur entreprise mais mais les gens qui
qui bossent ils veulent simplement qu'on
leur fiche la paix or en france la
spécialité c'est justement de leur
tomber dessus dès qu'ils ouvrent
l'entreprise est de ne jamais leur fiche
la paix et donc vous ne pourrez pas ni
réindustrialiser ni quoi que ce soit
c'est à dire que vous ne changeait pas
la donne qui font que les gens sont
partis et vous leur demander de revenir
ils sont pas fous ils sont très bien là
où ils sont et ils ne veulent pas
revenir donc si vous ne changez pas là
la donne que ce soit et pas simplement
fiscale c'est pas une question juste de
fiscalité c'est une question de de
stabilité juridique c'est une question
de 2-2-2
d'arrêter les revirements incessants
de politique un coup on met bz à cet
endroit ensuite on les retire donc
évidemment les entreprises se casse la
figure et settat on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui faire en france un business
plan sur cinq ans en se disant que la
l'environnement dans lequel on est
aujourd'hui sera l'environnement dans
lequel on sera dans cinq ans
l'environnement juridique fiscal et
c'est donc évidemment ça ne peut pas
marcher
un mot sur la chine avant de se quitter
à la chine qui pourrait profiter d'une
partie des plans de relance américains
et européens la relance de la
consommation en europe se traduit par
exemple par une hausse des commandes en
chine même chose avec le plan de joe
biden
la chine sera la grande gagnante
finalement la chine je sais pas ça sera
la grande gagnante mais de toute façon
pour ceux qui avaient oublié oui la
chine est encore lusine du monde
alors tout le monde a essayé de nous
faire croire que ça y est toutes les
entreprises avaient quitté la chine
était revenu en france et ailleurs non
c'est pas vrai ou aux etats-unis non
c'est pas vrai les laits vos téléphones
apple il continue à être fabriqués en
chine et assemblés au japon et pas et
pas aux états unis donc faut arrêter les
évidemment si vous avez une relance par
la consommation qu'est ce que vous
faites d'autant plus que vous n'avez pas
beaucoup d'argent parce que
le le les salaires sont bas et les
revenus sont bas qu'est ce que vous
faites vous achetez du chinois parce que
c'est moins cher tout simplement et donc
vous avez les exportations chinoises qui
se porte très bien merci monsieur by
donne et merci les autres plans de soi
disant relance et on écrit donné mon
rapidement sur la chine oui mais vous
achetez du chesnois je pense
qu'effectivement c'est clair vous
l'acheter via amazon et ça marche très
bien aussi je pense qu'on a jamais
autant dépendu effectivement de des
produits chinois c'est flagrant ça ne
s'adresse pas forcément des perspectives
mirobolante pour l'économie chinoise est
beaucoup plus complexe mais la
dépendance en termes de biens de
consommation est très clair skis et ski
marquant également je suis remarquer en
tant que consommateur c'est que
maintenant vous n'avez pas une toute
petite étiquette made in china cacher on
ne sait ou non c'est shenzhen en gros
sur des boîtes sur des colis ya vraiment
une montée en gamme également et je
terminerai d'un point de vue économique
quand vous regardez les détails de
l'économie chinoise c'est tout derniers
chiffres un notamment ce qui se passe
sur le front de l'investissement par
typologie d'entreprise parce qu'on a ces
données-là en chine donc entreprises
publiques privées à capitaux étrangers
et à l'investissement est en berne par
tous sauf de la part des entreprises
étrangères ce qui veut dire probablement
qu effectivement celles ci ont dû
investir davantage pour faire face au
surcroît de demande qui était
effectivement alimenté par les plans de
relance des occidentaux voilà pour la
petite histoire merci beaucoup merci
oui je ferais d'avoir été parmi nous
dans cette émission je rappelle que vous
êtes économiste et présidente de riches
florès reasearch olivier nous on
continue avec les questions et
commentaires cash
commentaires cette semaine sur
l'émission consacrée aux pandora peppers
je ne vois pas en quoi le fait que cette
fuite massive soit un faux scandale ce
n'est pas parce qu'on est au courant
depuis longtemps que ce n'est pas moins
scandaleux olivier mais tout à fait et
tout à fait monsieur dean sanguins ou
madame dean sans que je ne sais pas
c'est scandaleux mais ça n'empêche que
c'est ces soi-disant fuites sont des
fuites qui sont a priori
organisé et que
si vous voyez quelque chose change et
moi pas c'est à dire après les panama
après les lucs slicks les et caetera et
vous en aurez d'autres est probablement
c'est un peu comme les coop comme 21 22
23 24 25 26
donc vous en aurez d'autres simplement
ce que je remarque c'est que ça ne
change pas et ça vient souvent
de
2,2 on sent un peu la main l'américaine
derrière et
et curieusement c'est quand même chez
eux qui a les plus grosses blanchisseuse
c'est-à-dire dakota du sud c'est à dire
de la were c'est à dire je vous rappelle
que d'ailleurs monsieur by donne était
je crois gouverneur ou autre du deleware
donc on sent que ja b dès qu'ils sont
mentionnés dans cette enquête non mais
l'américain s'en vont on est d'accord la
seule chose je vous dis c'est que ces
paradis fiscaux res des paradis fiscaux
restent aussi des blanchisseuses pour
l'argent sale venus du monde entier et
que
scandale après scandale
est ce que ça change quelque chose non
parce que ils veulent tous finalement
tous ces grandes toutes ces grandes
puissances veulent avoir leur je dirais
leur blanchisseuse ils sont tout à fait
d'accord pour que on enlève les
blanchisseuses et copains mais pas les
leurs et ils c'est toujours la même
chose depuis depuis vingt ans que ça
dure parce que en effet
dans votre question vous dit que on est
au courant depuis longtemps oui on est
au courant depuis extrêmement longtemps
on n'a même pas attendu d'ailleurs les
fuites on sait comment ça fonctionne on
sait qu'il ya des paradis fiscaux
des les îles anglo-normandes enfin bon
il ya de tout temps les îles caïmans les
bahamas externe tout ça c'est connu et
reconnu depuis très longtemps la seule
chose c'est que je vois pas beaucoup
d'évolution donc et surtout chez ceux
qui ont l'air le plus remonté contre ce
contre ce genre de choses merci olivier
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
votre fidélité prochain rendez vous la
semaine prochaine en attendant pour voir
ou revoir nos précédents numéros rendez
vous sur notre site internet à l'adresse
rt france point tv et n'oubliez pas de
réagir à cette émission sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag rtcs h olivier
c'est à vous de la fin l'écouté fait
attention que la relance ne soit pas un
boomerang et qu'on le lance très loin
pour qu'il nous revienne très vite dans
la figure